You should have a better grasp on how to
use the material design guidelines to
make your app designs more immersive,
more bold, and more graphic.
>> We began the lesson with
a brief discussion of the Gestalt
principle of grouping.
We used it to add space to our designs,
and make them more easily scannable and
more quickly comprehensible.
>> Next was a discussion of color,
and how to create a color palette for
a brand and apply it to an app.
Then we discussed typography, and
how a clear hierarchy in type imbues
meaning into your user interface.
>> Last, we talked about imagery,
and learned how to pick photos and
illustrations that
are relevant to our users,
provided important information,
and were a delight to see.
>> Stay tuned for the next lesson,
where we'll talk about choreographing
the movement of digital paper and
ink through this concept
we call meaningful motion.